all right Indy hi India where'd you grow
up where are you from originally I'm
from Wisconsin right outside of
Milwaukee
Waukesha it's a really suburb sucks it's
super conservative
Republican and I hate it
tell me about your family
um so I was adopted through a Christian
organization
um a Christian adoption agency and
they're super religious and
they sheltered me a lot pretty
overbearing and pretty strict
that didn't work for your personality no
it didn't it didn't I was in trouble a
lot you think you just picked up some
things genetically from your biological
parents that just couldn't be probably I
probably did that would make a lot of
sense you know who your biological
parents are no no my uh biological
father isn't even on my birth
certificate at all and my biological
mother I know her name I think it's Lori
or something like you've never met her
no they actually had it
um on my adoption paperwork that I
couldn't even know their last name until
I turned 21 legally and then oh how old
do you know I'm 24. have you attempted
to do that I did well I didn't like look
too hard into it I looked up I looked
them up on Facebook and I couldn't find
anything so I just gave up it doesn't
really matter that much to me yeah
so given that conservative upbringing
you had
the religious upbringing how did you
get along with everybody in school or
your friends or your family
um so
I don't know I was always like really
quiet actually when I was younger I fed
into like a lot of those beliefs and
stuff
um until I turned maybe like 13 or
something because I'm bisexual so like
hearing all this land like how being gay
was a sin it just didn't make much sense
to me and that's when I really started
to form my own opinions but my brother
he was um the opposite of me he was
always like
very good listen to all the rules and
stuff and he was adopted as well yeah he
was probably my parents favorite but um
he is no longer a part of our family
anymore because when he turned 19 he
found his biological family and he got
legally I adopted as an adult I didn't
know that you could do that but he had
adopt it out of our family yeah so now
I'm the good child I'm an only child
what have you been doing with your likes
in school uh
uh
it's been an eventful like six years
you've been train hopping yeah well for
three and a half of those but before
that like when I was 19 I got a felony
for weed a pot like a pot conviction
um I got in trouble for selling an ounce
of weed and
they basically hit me with a bunch of
other charges so that I had to plead
guilty to manufacturing delivering THC
and then I got kicked off probation
because I was doing heroin so I did
almost a year in jail and then after
that I went on the road
and you've been traveling around the
country yeah yeah I have
um
I've been like 42 States I've seen
well I've seen I spent a lot of time on
the west coast I'm not gonna lie but
I've been all the way up to Vermont
um I haven't been up to Maine or Florida
or anything
um the first place I ever went was North
Platte Nebraska I
so it was kind of an impulsive decision
going on the road or whatever because I
was always restless and
um I had always like heard about train
hobby and thought it was cool
um so as soon as I got my felony like
taking care of her whatever I was like
I'm ready to go on the road and just
live my life so I hit up this kid I had
on Facebook
and they were like
well I asked them if they could teach me
how to train hop and they told me they
were like I guess I can they were kind
of reluctant but as soon as they told me
that they would I quit but with my jobs
on the spot and I bought a Greyhound
ticket and I left with like 30 dollars
tell me about the train happening
experience is it
is it scary going from one place
another where you don't even know
so that's where you're going I mean
sometimes
I mean there's been some times they've
been overwhelmed a little bit like the
first time I ever went to California and
I seen San Diego the city was so big it
was overwhelming but for the most part
it's never really been
too scary for me I like the feeling of
being in a new place a lot I
think that it's exhilarating I guess
you say and being a heroin addict does
that make it difficult to travel
um um so
I have like
so when I first the road I was cleaning
for a few months and then I used for a
couple months and then this is how I use
it so pretty sporadically it's on and
off but I mostly do Fentanyl now but
same same kind of addiction though yeah
yeah it sucks so when you're in
Wyoming or Arkansas where do you get
your Fentanyl
I don't
I
don't
um
I sometimes like
so like I told you I have a bunch of
like gaps of where I don't use
and um then when I am using I'll get
stuck in a place like I've gotten stuck
in Tucson for like a fat minute just
using vet but isn't the withdrawal
yeah it's uh it's uh it's because I'm
more of like a binge user
um I've been for like a month and then
I'll get clean again and the withdrawal
sucks but you know it is what it is I do
it to myself what's the longest you've
been clean from Fentanyl uh uh like nine
months I've been using six years and the
longest I've had it as a stretch is nine
months you've gotten clean from fentanyl
for nine months yeah I don't know a lot
of people that have done that yeah yeah
it wasn't easy
um I just relapsed in May
you got to stop that relapsing thing
I wish I wish it was that easy it's just
been like
pretty it's like a coping mechanism when
I get so stressed out and overwhelmed I
don't know what else to do but I mean
what do you think you're coping like
from
trying to cope with is your your
childhood no so
um
so in May I went down to Oakland
um because I had taken a little break
off the road and I uh went back to my
waitress I stayed in my parents garage
and I waitressed for a little bit and
then I went down to Oakland with some
money I'd saved up and I stayed with a
friend out there and got a job and I
relapsed
um
because of
um
just the abuse that I've been going
through in a relationship but then what
really made it what's really been making
it hard to quit was two months ago in
October
right before I left Oakland
um
something
I'm sorry
something really shitty happened
I went against my better judgment and
um
somebody had
silly
I got assaulted
um sexually yeah yeah they had a knife
to me
my throat and
um now I'm going to even told me they
were gonna
that there was
that they were gonna kill me no matter
what I did so I should just comply and I
really thought I was gonna die there so
I haven't been really cleaning at all
since then but you know
I'll get clean again eventually it's
horrible yeah yeah it happens but
for the most part I guess I'm pretty
lucky because in the three and a half
years I've been moving around and so
only
that only happened once
that that gnarly is something that bad
only happened once and that's why while
you were staying with your parents no
that was in Oakland when I was staying
with a friend oh I see yeah
and train hopping kind of helps you
escape from everything and
yeah I guess
I've been trying to figure out why why I
do it I think it's because I just like
leaving everywhere it is an escape I I
go somewhere I stay for a while and I
get so exhausted by everything and then
I just need to leave it's like
a breath of fresh air when you get into
a new place you know what I mean all
your troubles and responsibilities are
yeah erased you can just restart
um
and honestly the community on the road
is become my family
too so you're friends with uh crazy who
I've interviewed yeah it was crazy and
Max
and Sid yeah well I don't notice it yeah
I've known Max for like nine years I
really love I really love Mac that's
correct yeah
then how are they doing now they're
doing really they seem like they're
doing really well I just talked to Max a
couple of days ago but I just got a
phone for the first time in four months
so I haven't kept in as great of contact
with my friends as I'd like to but but
Max is no longer in LA right no Max is
in Milwaukee
um I know crazy he's doing really well
because I just hung out with them
I just got this piercing done with them
and I'm crazy
yeah yeah that dude sucks
his whole interview is just a mess even
hearing I think the whole thing was just
it was just a lie how would you take
five children on a freight train you
can't we strip a car seat to it no when
I when I saw coyote with
it's crazy I just I saw nothing but
trouble
yeah I mean it seems like that Dynamic
isn't that uncommon though on the road
there's always like an older guy with a
young girl yeah a lot of times there is
I think that um
I think that
a lot of times they prey on younger
women because
they offer safety or whatever I think a
lot of times people just don't respect
women on the road at all and they just
don't think that we know what we're
doing so they offer safety or whatever
but I've already been there done that so
I'm done with that
I'm done with that but in general you
like the train hopping lifestyle yeah I
do I do like the dream hobby lifestyle I
mean I there's a freedom to it there's a
freedom to it I would say it's no harder
um than living in a house so it's no
easier or harder because living in a
house you have you know you spend your
whole life working and having responses
like it just gets stressful it gets just
as stressful as it does being on the
road I I would say it's got its ups and
downs life does regardless but I I'm
just so restless but I need to keep
moving do you think you might be ADHD I
do have 80 ADHD actually yeah
maybe that and also just a lot of angst
I don't really know what I'm doing and
like
where would you like to be in five ten
years what are your dreams
um I'd like to have a van
you don't have kids in a job no it was
fun to have a family yeah but I have a
bad
I I really like I've got a dog already
so that's that's enough for me but I'd
really like to get the van for my dogs
and me and her can just chill and we can
travel the country and like stop when we
want to and get jobs because then I'd
have a place to live because it's not so
easy to just go somewhere and get a job
when you don't have a place to live
um you know what I mean did you even
have a driver's license no I don't I
have to get back
yeah I just lost the ID like two days
ago yeah as a fentanyl addict no no no
fentanyl attic has their ID I had mine
for a long time dude and literally just
lost it I'm pretty bummed about it the
final wax here on Skid Row just gets
stripped clean of everything every time
because when they sleep they're
basically yeah
a dead carcass and everyone knows that
they can just yeah that's why I don't
know sleep on streets like that though
like Skid Row like I wouldn't ever like
pass out on Skid Row or hang out there
too long what are you doing on skid row
now that's where I found you well I'm
doing I just I I mean I would go to cop
to pick up but like not to sleep you
know like you're one of the few ones
that's honest yeah like I came down here
to do drugs but I definitely like
I know better than to Camp where you cop
that's not a good idea yeah because
there's too many people stealing I'll
take a Transit bus out to like a suburb
and I'll pass out
and under a bridge or something by
myself that's one of the things I
learned
um train hopping
um you never uh you never wanted stage
shelters well at least that's how I was
taught there's like rules to it too it's
not just like hopping trains there's
like
a whole lifestyle level like it we just
do homeless different uh we don't stay
in shelters you don't camp in tent
cities ever ever
um you stay by yourself
for the most part or with the other
traveling Community
um and I think it's better that way
honestly because I've noticed a lot of
like 10 cities and local homeless
communities they have a huge issue with
still like people stealing all their
stuff yeah everything everyone here gets
right all the time every time they sleep
yeah that uh when I was down in San Fran
actually down in the tenderloin I like
but I would go there to Coffee News but
um I would count like how many times per
day I would hear somebody like freak out
because they got all their stuff stolen
actually it's kind of sad I did meet
this one kid and they look kind of
bummed out so I asked them what was
wrong one day and I was like did you get
something stolen from you and he said no
because he said no I get stolen from
twice a week everything I own I don't
even care anymore
by saying is that the state bird down
here on Skid Row is somebody laying on
the sidewalk with their shoes gone and
their pockets stuck out like rabbit ears
yeah dude uh because everything they own
except maybe their pants and especially
if you're an opiate addict too like you
know you're gonna nod off and you should
probably you know not do that where
everybody's gonna steal from you but I'm
pretty nice about things I'll wake
people up all the time when I see them
nodded off I wake him up I hand them out
their stuff when they get and they drop
their their purses or their wallets I
always tell them they're lucky that they
ran into me because I'm really nice I'm
not going to steal from them
what emotions do you go through living
this lifestyle what emotions are you
depressed or anxious angry I've been
really depressed lately it
um
the friend of Mozart that's all I've
really been feeling is just really
really depressed but sometimes I feel
happy
um
sometimes it's like it's been really
good
and what
sorry sometimes
sometimes it's very very soothing to me
on the road I felt like
I felt like when I first went on the
road
it was very healing
um
because
you don't have very many distractions
it's just you
um you're not worried about material
possessions or when you have to pay rent
and you have a lot of time to focus on
yourself and
um really get to know yourself and
um
even though
it's not always good sometimes even
though it's not always easy
sometimes
um
I'm sorry I don't
it's not always easy but it's worth it
to live like that because right now like
I am pretty depressed but you know I
don't
I have the ability to be able to feel
that feel those emotions and work
through them and really self-reflect
you are
did you feel loved when you were a kid
um
not really
um my brother
was
super uh
but me and my brother were obviously
it's who I am but he was like very
social
then athletic and he was you know like
sheep of the family yeah yeah I was you
felt misunderstood by everybody yeah and
they always made it like I always used
to get yelled at for
um being depressed or having anxiety a
lot
um
I don't really know why
I haven't yelled at me for that I used
to go in my clothes put a chair in my
closet and I would cry in my closet
but
um my mom
me and my mom are good on better terms
now she got on meds
and
she went to therapy and
I mean it's better now that's all that
matters I try not to think about my
childhood too much and what could have
went better because
it
it happened it is what it is and like my
parents are just people too
because if I had kids like if I had a
kid right now I would
they would be [ __ ] I would not know
what I'm doing so I owe no resentments
to my parents there was no abuse or
anything in your childhood
um so like
the thing is that um put soap in my
mouth like liquid soap
um when I would like
say bad words or have an attitude or
whatever they put a timer on because the
Tabasco sauce didn't work well I liked
hot sauce to do it but liquid soap in my
mouth and I would have to hold it to a
timer so it would burn uh they I've
always had a wooden spooning uh
um just
um
so that as a reminder so that I wouldn't
do bad stuff but I got to think that
every day she broke it on my mom broke
it on my back one time
when I was uh like pretty young I was
like maybe five or six and she broke the
wooden spoon over my back
but
um I guess those things are
abuse I I mean I always thought that it
was normal
growing up but I'm not really
sure that it is now and I don't think
that's so normal yeah
what's your biggest fear what do you
worry about now
um
so I am almost 25 in February
and
I'm sorry I keep almost crying
um I was 25 in February and I'm just
like
really scared
I'm scared that I'm not gonna that I'm
gonna spend another year like unhappy
because I don't want to do that anymore
it was like the past two years I've been
in a relationship that's really been
not
has been really draining I really love
them
it's been really draining and
I've been thinking about that a lot
actually women
and I I'm really I'm really scared that
I'm gonna turn 25 and I'm gonna spend
another year
just
feeling like a shell you know a person
it's gonna be up to you to make a change
yeah you're right
you can't expect him to or her to
straighten out
this is hard because I
I am
it's hard for me to let people go
again when I love people I love them
like Bully so it's like really hard for
me to like put myself first yeah but
you'll pay a price for every
stand you take so
you just have to understand that that
stand is
making you miserable yeah yeah you're
right
you're young yet you have to
yeah and easy on yourself
you can't be expected to know everything
yeah that's true at your age
okay I'm getting there I'm getting old
almost kind of I'm almost like 25 is a
quarter to a hundred so
did you like to live all over again
would you have done anything differently
no
no you didn't take a sec you didn't take
a second to answer that one no I've
already thought about that before and
um
I wouldn't because oh even the things
that have really sucked all those
lessons I feel like were important and I
think they make me who I am today
um a lot of things like even be an
addict and stuff like you know
eventually hopefully I'll figure it out
one day and I'll get clean but
um
um
other things that happened I didn't have
to have to do with do it other things
that happen to me that deal with my
trauma or
that caused my trauma I still wouldn't
undo that either because it makes me
um as empathetic as I am and I don't
think I would be like that if I hadn't
been through a lot of the stuff that I
had been through
because I like being able to understand
other people's struggles
something like that
back to the train hopping is train
hopping dangerous at times I hear all
these terrible stories
there are terrible stories from where I
like coyote that seen so many kids die
when I watch the interview I have not
seen
I mean I've had I've had a friend die on
the dream but like if you think about it
trains derail a lot less than cars crash
so
if you know what you're doing then
you're gold
but I probably
um
probably shouldn't have said that
sometimes
um
we try to I don't know sometimes we want
people to stay off the rails so yes it's
very dangerous you're trying to
discourage people from doing yeah
and tell me what would you say is the
most important lesson you've learned in
your life
it was important lesson
probably yeah
probably that other people don't feel
things the way that I feel things
because that's like something that
that's actually the lesson that I've
learned most recently that's caused a
lot of like damage in my life is I I
don't understand why people do things
and I think that just because I wouldn't
do something or because I would do
something that somebody else would do
that but just because I feel certain
emotions I mean other people have the
same motives or
conscious that I do they don't we're all
aware differently yeah yeah that's for
sure
yeah
all right Andy thank you so much for
sharing your story yeah thank you be
careful out there
good luck
thank you